you guys ready
good evening
i'm captain carlos hank let's spell
c-a-r-l-o-s-h-a-n-k
from the office of internal oversight
las vegas metropolitan police department
i'm here today to brief you on
the ninth officer-involved shooting in
lvmpd's jurisdiction this year
on today november 16 2021
officers
were
called to the 2100 block of north pecos
reference a person with a gun call
upon arrival
the officers located
the subject
that was matched in the description
provided by the witnesses
when the officers contacted the subject
subject immediately fled from the
officers
after a short foot pursuit
the subject produced a handgun and
pointed it at the officers
to defend themselves the officers
pulled their handguns
and
fired
at the suspect
striking him and causing him to fall to
the ground
the officers then rendered aid and
someone medical to the scene
the suspect was then transported to a
local hospital
where he received uh where he was in uh
where he had non-life-threatening
injuries sorry about that
these are the preliminary details as we
know them
a member of executive staff will come
before you within 72 hours to provide
additional details
thank you
i'm sorry could you speak up a little
bit what was the circumstance
circumstances that we know it right now
is a preliminary
that a witness called in stated there
was a subject outside with a firearm
it was a member of the community that
was in the in the community the exact
person i don't know at this time
uh is a uh
black male adult that's all i can tell
you at this time
anybody else arrested besides this
person
is anyone else arrested was that what
you that's your question
i do not have those details at this time
uh
the details that we know right now is
the subject that hold the gun on the
officers is a subject that we uh that
we're going to going to arrest
and where was the suspect shot
i don't have those details
thank you all i appreciate your time
tonight thank you for hanging out with
us good night
you